proof.
Yeah.
So, we haven't been doing like I haven't
done cognto and to be honest for the SAP
cognto is essential.
So, I have never done I've never taught
cognto in the class. I've just taught
other things kind of just went away from
cognto and I finally had a diff not only
a reason to teach cognto but a
methodology to teach cognto. So if I
have those together then I'll teach it
to you. So before I was kind of like,
eh, I can just power through it and I
don't really need it for the class, not
for what you guys are doing. But since
we're doing uh IM in sir one, we might
as well do Cognto here. You know what I
mean? We might as well do Olaf 2. We
might as well get JWT done here. Do
those kind of things here in this class
because it's going to be necessary like
in the other class. It's It's going to
be a big thing coming through. So, I
want you guys to do it here.
Not yet. SS we're not we're doing SSO
mainly in Seir 1. Sir 1 is going to
introduce a massive SSO because we have
to deal with your best friend out there,
Azure. So, I need an SSO for that.
So, let me go ahead and
put this here.
Hold on. So, here you go.
Um, so I cannot take this
wide screen. It's just too bright. Give
me a second. I have to go get my
password in the other computer so I can
log into GitHub here because I don't
know my password. So, give me a second.
I'll be right back.
Does this mean I can't get frustrated at
people when they
lose their passwords 5 minutes after
making them love?
>> No.
>> Should I be frustrated with him?
>> There's no point.
>> Okay, you're right.
It's
people will he go he goes to the beat of
his own drum can't can't do anything
about it so you you expect logic it's
not not happen not
>> you've seen the chat with him lately
>> I I forum
>> the admin one I'm like I like looked
this morning at my messages and I was
like I sound really upset when I sent
these messages And I was like, well, I
think I was a little upset.
>> Yeah, cuz when you ask for you ask for a
answer to a question, you're like, okay.
He answers him. Answers him. Answers
him. I'm asking you a question. I kind
of need this. I'm supposed to I kind of
need you to tell me what's going on
here.
>> No answer. Okay. Yeah. finally extract
the information and then I hear five
minutes later it's different.
>> Indeed.
Indeed. So
the answer is just to be someone that he
has to reach out to.
That's that's what usually happens.
It it it happens in a lot of families.
I'll say that, you know, the the guys
that are a bit more dependable, they
they they get more uh b they get more
objectives and less uh less uh help,
we'll say. But the guys that need more
help or the, you know, the family
members that need more help, they get
more attention and it's like, hold on,
hold on.
So
>> yeah, I don't know, Rob. Rob's volume is
a bit low.
>> Using the headset. You got no I wish
>> we know where you're at, Rob. We know
you're in the backyard getting the tears
and we know that's it. You want the
venison? That's fine.
>> Venison. No,
>> let me wait a second. That reminds me of
a news story I saw about Nigerians.
>> Great. What's the story about the
Nigerians? Go ahead.
>> Hold on. Making fun of Rob for being
Nigerian is a hobby of mine.
>> You know, you you can't I'm I got to
accept it because I I appreciate my my
country where my my genealogy comes
from, but I can't I can't front scammers
come out there, man.
Hey, man. Joe offer shout shout out to
um who does it best? Uh
West Africa not Nigeria. Nigeria does
not do it good. It's not as good as
other places cuz
>> it's not Sagal. It's not good.
>> Exactly. Sagal is the number one.
I I'll admit that. Um
uh migrant Oh god.
Oh,
>> or
>> the food the food looks good. There's a
little It It's probably the majority of
the black people in my county. There's
like a uh Nigerian market like that.
They cook some food. I've seen their
like pictures. It looks good.
>> Okay. So there there are tribes in
Nigeria that will legitimately cook
animals like domesticate animals. Why? I
don't know but they just do it. It's not
this is not surprising to me because
it was not surprising
>> guys guys. So it's eating okay if you
look at the war in Ukraine
for the Russian army. What is one of the
big sources of protein?
>> People
are they eating people?
>> Dogs.
>> Well, there you go.
>> They go around Ukraine finding dogs and
eat them.
It's been this way since 2022. I've been
following it, particularly with the
Siberians, uh, military regiments.
So, I give money to um dog shelters in
Notesa so that they can shelter their
dogs and keep them away from the front
line because if the Russian army comes
anywhere near, they'll either kill the
dogs or eat them.
>> Well,
both.
>> So, it's not unusual. I want to say that
something like that is going on. I mean,
I wouldn't have I wouldn't call I I
would call the police because it's a
public disturbance. So, I wouldn't put
the guy in jail because I'd be like, I
coming from
>> Yeah, I I get it. I mean, they're not
it's not as I want to say, it's not
double worshippers.
>> It's something that I don't like.
>> It's it's a cultural standard that is
not translating to the new spot that
they're at. And no one gave them a crash
course. So, they're just like, I'm just
going to find food wherever. And it's
not not how it works
>> because you know the the Indians worship
cows. A lot of Indians worship cows,
right? So when we eat hamburgers, they
think we're barbaric.
Just saying. They think we're
barbarians.
A lot of them are vegetarians.
>> They eat cats in Switzerland and France,
too, by the way.
>> They they what?
>> They eat cats as well. Some people eat
cats as well. Well, well, it's snails
eat frogs,
>> right?
>> So,
what is
Japanese eat dolphins, which pisses me
off, also eat whale, also pisses me off.
Two very intelligent creatures. Why you
would do that, I have no idea. Um, so
can't can't ding Nigerians for doing
that.
It it itself doing it in a in a park.
Okay. But can't think I mean it's
just roll the eyes and keep on going.
That's it.
Yeah. I don't know. Yeah. He seals too.
Yeah. America's love investigate. Yeah.
So,
so when
believe me when when Russians like eat
dogs, I'm very tempted to go get a
Russian and you know pull a what is it?
A Game of Thrones move on them. Make
sure my dogs are vanished. Go get some
real dogs like a cane curso and an
Anatolia and put some barbecue sauce on
them like you like that. Okay. Yeah,
you're for dinner now, bud. But okay,
that's enough for me. Um,
uh, so you guys, uh, can see my repo,
right? See the Lambda repo right here?
Because was everybody able to get their
Lambda repo?
>> Yes, sir.
>> Okay. So, these are various labs that
I've been working on. Um, they're
basically designed to give you a lot of
work, a lot of goals to have with
Lambdas. some of the lessons I'm
actually expanding. And so you see
lesson B, that's where we're going to
start from today. That's where I'm going
to start from now. Um, we can do things
with there, but I just want to say like
you're seeing all these other labs in
there. A lot of that time that's for you
to go in there and get an idea of what
you want to do. I haven't actually given
the instructions, but I'm giving you an
idea of something that you can do with a
lamp. So try to go figure it out on your
own. Um, one of the reasons why I'm
doing this hold on where the whole app
is under function. Well, we're
we're moving towards that black muscle
in in this part where we're have we
actually have to build it out that takes
it's going to take a while to do that.
Um, the reason why I'm doing this is
giving you guys additional labs is uh
always we've had people say, "Give me
more lambdas. Give me more examples."
And what I'm doing, I'm just throwing a
lot of examples uh at you all the time.
Um, I have to remember this. Uh, admins,
keep me honest with this one. Uh, class
six, we never really went over Lambda.
Well, before we kind we kind of just did
a little bit, but we never did it as as
to the degree that I wanted to. And now
I'm going to the degree that I want to.
So class six needs to have an olive
branch given out to them. And the guys
who
we are in class to a certain degree and
I was trying to do lambdas. They need to
be invited to come to the class and
actually participate in lambda class.
This is going to this is going to last a
few months and I want them to go and
participate in this. So yeah, I don't
want to leave them behind. That's
something I kind of feel bad about that
we didn't do. Uh, so to recap, I was I
was half listening. So to recap, you're
saying you want people who
>> fell off, you want us to pull them back
in.
>> No, I think he meant class six.
>> Class six.
>> Yeah. People that fell off in class six,
you want them to come back in.
>> Yeah. So PE like
>> I think he just means all of class six.
>> Yeah. So, anyone in class 6 um if they
want to come into class 7 and
participate in the lambda section
including the terraform section and the
Jenkins section and the Armageddon they
can't because I'm going to be doing
event um based or what event driven
architectures here. I'm going to be
doing IM, I'm going do APIs,
those kinds of things. And I didn't do
that with them. And I want to make sure
that they get this exposure.
So I only went to a certain section with
them and then that class basically
stopped because I was overwhelmed with
work and now I want to go ahead and
bring them back in. Okay. But only for
this section.
Okay. Okay. So
yes, yes. So um that is that is correct.
So basically what we're doing in this
section is we're building up to a a part
where we can actually have the entire
compute be serverless and then I'm going
to have aentic AI be a part of this as
well but it's kind of not exactly the
way you would think because it is
serless. So it's like where do you put
the AI agent? We're going to have to
talk about that but where do you put
aentic AI or where do you use bedrock in
conjunction with lambdas? So there is a
place to do this. All right. So what I
want is uh today I want two people to
share their screens because there's two
sections to this and I want you guys to
be showing this. I'm going to be going
through the documentation and showing
you what to do. Um this teaching
methodology I'm also going to be doing
in class 7.5.
Uh my one of the critiques that I have
is that I was sharing the screen too
much and basically I we want to have
more time with the students sharing
their screen and actually showing
running everything where I'm just the
teachers directing. Um this is to make
sure you guys get more screen time
because we can see what you're doing.
That's kind of an important thing. We
already know what teachers can do. We'll
make sure you guys can do it. Um, so
yeah, S3, Lambda, uh, yeah, CF, all the
thing here. Yeah, that's all going to be
a part of the of this class. It's all
down.
>> Just now realizing apparently I can't
spell Aurora.
>> Aurora. That's right. That's okay
because I don't care. I can't There's a
lot of things I can't spell. All right.
So, first thing, um, here I go ahead and
give a walk through and I'm telling you
basically what's doing, uh, what's going
on here. In this lab, we're going to
have two lambdas running and have one
API gateway. It's very basic.
Nothing going to be um nothing big on
here to be honest. The big thing with
Lambda, as I'm sure Aaron told you guys
last week, is that this is all like this
is pure code. The pure code execution.
There's no patching. There's no well
there's there'll be vulnerability in the
code, but there's no underlying
infrastructure vulnerability, right? So
this is good. Uh what I'm doing today in
today's class is going to be lambda
walkthrough, API walkthrough, and the
WAP walkthrough. I think you can get
through all three. Um and then uh the
JWT walkthrough, I have to keep on
working with that because there is the
oaf
the off zero account and I have to make
sure everything is cool with that. Um,
how many Just want to ask you guys real
quick. How many of you guys have a
registered domain? Like that's your
registered domain
like Oblock Vixens.
You know what I mean? Wait. Oblak fixes.
Who Who would have that? I don't know.
Okay.
So, okay. Gordon, what you got?
>> Oh, sorry. I I thought you were saying
raise hands if you had
>> Oh. Oh, that's apologies.
>> Yeah. Sorry. I'm looking for a one in
the chat.
>> Yeah. Apologize Gordon for doing exactly
what he said.
>> Sorry.
>> Hey, I' I've been punished for less.
>> So, okay, you got a one chat. Who does
not have their own registered domain?
>> Put a two in the chat if you don't have
your own registered domain.
Okay, so everybody here has their own
registered domain. Okay, that's
important. I needed to ask you guys that
because you can't do the uh off the zero
lab without that. I want to make sure
everybody have their own domain. So now
that you have it, it's good. You guys
got it. They should because of Armagon.
That's right. I know. I know yours be
Oblock something. Larry, I'm looking out
for you. All right. So I can go ahead
and work on that one to make sure this
is done correctly. Okay. So I'm gonna go
through here and go through the lambda
walkthrough. Um just remember
this is how I've the new setup since
Armageddon.
Uh I have this new way of doing things.
So the code is always going to be here
always. So, I have a folder for your
code. And as I'm teaching the lesson,
um, the one to walk through, I'm going
to give you a place to actually click
on. You can actually go get the code.
That's because I I put the hyperlink in
there correctly, but I I always supply
the code to, right? I don't want to make
you guys have to go out and get your own
code. That's kind of been um a a a an
irritance. I I don't want to do that
anymore. I want to always have sample
code. Always have sample Terraform. You
can take it from there. All right. Uh,
wait, wait. What is this?
Kirk. Kirk. No, I didn't. No, I didn't
want. No, I didn't know I'd read that.
No. Okay. Anyway,
um, we're going to be doing two
um two lambdas today. One's going to be
Python, and the other one's going to be
Node.js. So to the person who wants to
do the Python part
who uh can they please share your screen
and the person who wants to do the
NodeJS part can you please share your
screen who wants to do this
because I'm sharing my screen with
following with doing the instructions
>> just call on two people.
>> Well I mean I've been with these guys
for a while. I don't think they'll be
that scared.
>> Yeah, just do it.
>> Who? I kind of called on y'all to do
this. Really?
>> You guys got to understand like when he
says, "Who wants to do the walk through
for the first time?" He's about to show
you this is the kind of help you wish
you had all the time. So, you might as
well just be like me. I'd do it if I
wasn't an admin to be honest with you.
>> I mean, I'll go ahead and do one. It was
uh one was Python. What was the other
one?
>> Okay. No. JS.
>> I'll do the other one.
>> Okay. So,
>> I'll do the Python.
>> Okay. So, Kirk's gonna do Python. So,
share your screen. And Catchy is going
to do Coachi. Couchy.
>> Coach. Call me Coach.
>> Coach. Coach. Okay. Coach is going to do
Node.js. All right. So, share your
screen.
Allow. Yes.
>> Coach, you have such patience because I
think I would still be saying your name
wrong if you didn't just say that.
>> It's been a lifetime. No worries. I'm
used to it.
>> In Japan, people got my name wrong all
the time, and I just had a tolerance. I
said, "This is how you say it."
>> Well, you you guys speak the same
language, though.
>> Okay. So, we got Kirk. Okay. So, Kirk,
go. So, I need you to log into your
console, your AWS console.
For some reason, Theo, I I get this
middle image of very polite Japanese
people pronouncing your name Teodor as
opposed to Teodor.
>> Uh, so T
is actually not a
actual Japanese sound.
There's not actually a way of doing it
officially in Japanese. They actually
have to know about English first and
then they try to do it from there
because um TI is officially chi. So chi,
they got a plenty of chi but no t.
And so th doesn't exist either, but most
European languages don't have th.
So T, my name is T E that comes from
Greek and the T has a hyphenation on it
that has as has as aspiration.
So the H was added in order to add
aspiration. It's supposed to be T like
that t.
But the English had a th sound which was
they had a different letter for it. So
that became the it's actually t in Greek
but the the English they looked at the e
and said I for whatever reason and then
they saw the aspiration and they said
that was th like that sound. So it's do
in English but it's actually in European
language it's tea tail do
that's actually how my language is
supposed my language supposedly say
it's fodder
just like you know like fodder
that's theor Michael my name is actually
Michael
I had to go study my name. I was like,
"Oh, this what my name actually gave me
that."
All right.
Okay. So, uh, coach, I need you to bring
up your AWS
um, prompt. And Kirk, okay, you got it.
Okay. So, what I want you to do, Kirk,
is uh, go to Lambda.
Okay. So, what we're first going to do
here for both of you is going to go to
uh lambda create function. Both of you
guys going to be okay.
Kirk coach, you're not sharing your
screen. You're not sharing your you
don't have your AWS prompt up.
>> Is it? Okay. Hold on. I must have messed
it up then. Hold on a second. All right.
>> Yeah, you're sharing. We see your
desktop with like a castle.
>> Castle. I like the castle.
>> It is a pretty castle.
There we go.
>> Okay, everybody go dark mode.
Dark mode, please. I had to go log in
here to go dark mode. Okay, let's do
dark mode so we don't lose our eyes.
>> I completely forgot how to do that on
here.
>> You click the settings cog
>> next to your region.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay, thank you.
>> Dark like my soul. talk.
All right. Great function. There you go.
Okay. So, you're gonna go Kirk, you're
going to do task two right here. Add
Python code right there. Okay. And
um Couchi, you're going to do task five.
>> And it's the same it's the same process
on each one of them. Okay. We're
watching you guys now. For you guys at
home, you should be following along. Of
course, right? I'm gonna see how you
>> probably asking questions if they have
any.
>> I know you guys have lots of questions,
of course. Um, now remember with both of
these, the only way, what is the only
way that you can upload um,
uh, Python or NodeJS code into a lambda?
What do you have to do first to the to
the code?
>> Oh, you have to zip. You have to uh
package it in a zip, I believe.
>> You have to zip it.
>> Is that correct? Yeah. Yeah.
>> Got to zip it. So, just so you know,
you're going to have to get Visual
Studio Code open. That's the easiest way
to do it. You have to go Visual Studio
Code. You have to save it. And then you
have to do the zip um have to do the zip
command in order to get to work. Okay.
>> All right. for sweetness.
Okay,
>> let's go to work. See what you're doing
there.
>> I think I am on the wrong
We're in lesson B.
>> Yes. Look at my screen.
>> So, you are no.JS. You are task five.
Lesson B lab A lambda walk through
>> and you are you're in the right place
couch c coach so yeah you're good
>> okay perfect all right task five repeat
same process
>> boom
you choose navigate there permissions
okay configuration this is going to have
to be this will have to be there choose
author from scratch function
except what you're going to do. Your
name is going to be Chewbacca node
lambda and let me put it down here. Hold
on. Where's your cast?
Here it is.
>> Which I would say for this so far, it's
pretty much the same as last week's lab.
>> Yep.
>> Okay,
>> there it is. So,
there you go. So for you, you're going
to have to do Chebacca. Your name's
going to be Chewbacca node lambda. Your
runtime's going to be Node.js. In
permissions, you're going to create a
new role.
Okay. Exactly the same thing you guys
did last week. We look at Kirk, see what
he's doing. That's right. So you got
Kirk has Python 3.5.
Okay. Good.
Okay.
>> Really quickly. So, I did uh
I guess I got a question cuz last week
we did it uh cuz this is just a simple
handler.
>> We ran that right in the uh in the
lambda. We didn't have to zip it.
So,
this should work. Don't have to zip it.
I I'll just run it in the lambda first.
Yeah. Go ahead. Go see how should be
fine.
Okay,
very good. So, yeah. So, you create a
basic role. You guys did this last week.
Very good. Okay. Good.
>> Man, you guys are fast.
>> That's why Keha fails.
Wait a minute. Did I Did I say something
like that?
>> Yeah, it's in uh where did I just read
that?
Replace default code with and then you
have the Python script and then it goes
note if you don't deploy nothing change
AWS is not psychic. This is why Kha
fails.
>> Okay, where are we?
>> Did I say that?
>> I don't I don't believe I said that.
>> Co coach, were you in the IM console?
Hold on. I go back.
>> Yes, sir.
>> So, we should be able to
>> to create a new role.
>> Oh, I guess I I could use the same one
then. Yeah.
>> Yeah.
>> Well, so it says if it you see in the
file, so you're on task five, right?
>> Right.
>> We didn't do that.
>> Uh permissions create new role
parenthesis basic lambda. Yeah,
>> pretty sure what he's referring to is
the basic execution role for Lambda,
which is a AWS managed role.
>> Copy.
Okay,
>> what you got?
>> So, uh just minor uh uh housekeeping. I
think I'm maybe a half step behind. Um
so on the uh the lambda creation page
you just input uh uh Python uh 3.4 3.14
is the runtime named it and then
continued. Am I correct?
>> Yeah. Yeah. It's it's in the
instructions.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> Wait. Where the where are the
instructions? I'm sorry. I I must look
look at my screen.
I put all of these steps now in the
instructions in in the in the repo
before I teach.
>> Oh, okay. Yeah. The second question was
the the Python a little easier for you
guys.
>> Oh, that total. Well, yeah. Yeah. You
got to remember I'm I'm 5.5, so I'm I'm
not used to these wonderful amenities
that you got going on. I'm I'm thankful.
I'm appreciative. Don't get me wrong. I
just wasn't expecting it.
>> Be be thankful for therapy.
>> Thank you.
We be thankful for therapy Theo. Therapy
Theo started changing a little bit. So,
uh yeah, that's just the way things are.
Okay. So, what's your next question?
>> Next question.
>> Does that exist? What did I do?
>> The uh the Python uh file that I saw in
your VS code. I know that it's in this
repo. I'm not sure where exactly it is.
>> Well, hold on. You have to look look at
my screen. Look at the instructions.
says add Python code replace default
code with and then what does it say
after that
look at my screen
Kirk you you see it says on task three
test lambda fun uh lambda click test
create new test event uh he create Theo
can't create new lines but anyway name
test Python use this JSON. So for the
event
with the test event feature, you're
going to use that JSON he supplies right
there.
Oh, okay. Hold on. Where are we at?
So I was on another screen. So when I
make a test here
>> Yep.
>> With the Is it
not showing?
>> It did. Help it.
>> Oh, my trip.
>> Okay.
Oh, I'm running the test I already made.
I have to edit it.
>> So,
edit the text.
>> Click uh create new test event bottom
left.
>> Oh, I see. It's a little clutter. Okay.
All right. We'll just do Theo's
test
and then
I should have read was that code here
that he supplied.
>> You could just copy it. Has a little It
has a little trares in there. Go to the
right.
>> Oh, right. Right here.
>> Yeah, right here. Yep.
>> Yeah, I overlooked it. Thank you.
There's a word for that I recently
signed like UI design theory where
there's like originally they were pieces
of paper but now they're just squares
because the meaning doesn't really
matter.
>> Oh, that's interesting.
>> It's like it's like a floppy disc for
saving it, but there's lots of people
that don't really know what floppy disc
is for, but they just recognize it as as
a symbol for saving.
>> Test it. Yeah, I think that's like those
it's like artifacts from something
previous like like haptic touch or or
lines on your notes when you're typing
something.
>> Um,
>> one example I've seen is uh like a an
image of a videape uh to symbolize
video.
>> Hold on. Hold on. Um, Kirk, go back to
go back to Lambda. Go back to the
output.
No,
>> I'm right here. I'm in there. Output.
>> Scroll down. Scroll down.
>> Did you run the new test? It doesn't
look like you ever ran the new test.
>> Oh, cuz I didn't.
>> Click save.
>> I have to save it. It's not real.
>> Wait a minute. What did I say? If you
click deploy,
if you don't deploy, nothing changed.
AWS is not psychic. This is why Kesha
fails. So test and then deploy
there. Good. Go. Hey, help.
>> Oh, there we go. It's Chewbacca now.
Okay,
>> Chewbacca.
>> Thank you.
>> Oh, so we'll see see what coach is
doing.
Okay,
hold on. So let's do the same thing for
you.
>> So do you have a test event coach?
>> I did
>> and I execution function failed. I went
to logs.
>> No, no. Just go go back to code.
>> Okay.
>> Go down. You don't have a test event.
Click uh the test button.
>> Yep.
>> Click create new test event.
I I told you what to name but Chewbacca
node lambda. I told you
I spent all that time documentation.
>> Okay. So, scroll down right.
>> Yep. And then replace that Jason there.
Okay. He has it. He has Malcus on. Okay.
>> Yep. So, uh, save that.
Screw up. Save.
>> Oy. There we go.
>> Okay.
Then deploy.
Okay. And test.
>> All right. Did I Yep, that's the right
one.
Uh,
>> hey, were you meeting with Dcoin?
Maybe he is right now.
>> This tiqs.
Okay.
Scroll down. Um
>> here. Make sure. Did you actually invoke
it though?
Yeah, invoke it.
>> Mhm.
>> There you go.
Did
>> I say invoke
is say event already exists. It's been
invoked.
Um
exports is not defined in ES module
scope.
What the sweetness does that mean?
>> School helping.
Oh, yep. That's the word Kirk
>> from the hello to
bench.
Hold on. Can you look at the out? Can I
see the output again?
>> Oh, sweetness. There we go.
Why can't we make this bigger?
>> That's what she said.
>> Oh. Oh, I'm so bad.
I'm so bad.
>> There's the output. Okay.
>> Good. J, good job. Ja. Good job.
Has anyone got the node to work?
>> Let's do yours again.
>> I think I have an idea of why it's not
working. Scroll up a bit.
>> Scroll up in the in the output or on the
screen.
>> On the screen.
Okay.
>> Like Yeah. So I can see the error
message. Uh not the console. Sorry.
Gotcha.
>> Is that the scroll? Is there anything
else
or is that it?
That's it.
Okay.
>> Express is not to find an ES module
scope.
All right. All right. Google. Let's see.
App file
one. One.
Okay.
All right. Yeah. So, show me the code.
It I think this is cuz Theo probably
made a zip file
and you
>> Oh, yeah. This is ind index.mjs.
So, uh, can will it let you rename the
file to index.cjs?
>> Looks like it. Then deploy it.
Okay.
>> Okay. And then try and run the test
again.
>> Succeeded.
Cool beans.
There we go. Okay,
that's what we wanted.
Okay, so got the lo got the log events.
Good. You went to there.
Okay,
>> hello Malgus from Node.
>> There you go.
>> Good. Yes, that is that was a part of
the instructions. You're supposed to go
to Cloud Watch and look for the
hopefully events and you did it. Great
job, coach.
>> Thank you. Thank you. Thanks for the
help.
>> Hey, we're all helper. It's all we're
here for.
>> Okay.
>> I know what you said. Make it bigger.
So,
>> we're here for you, man.
>> He has a unusual reaction.
Okay. So you guys at home, you need to
do
both of them. You need to do node and
lambda. Okay?
If you only do one, it's fine. You could
actually only do one if you want to. The
reason why I'm doing two lambdas today
is to make sure you understand that you
can do lambdas in different languages.
So I don't want you to think you have to
do one language for one lambda and
lambda for another one. They're pretty
much the same. There's really not that
big of a difference between these two.
So, one says hello like hello from
Chebacca and the other one says hello
from Malibus.
That's all it is, right?
Whatever gets you paid, Carlton, I don't
care as long as you get paid. That's all
I care about. Can you get paid?
I care. I care that you could go into a
group of men and say, "You [ __ ] I
make this much money per year. It's
because of this program. It was so easy
to do and I'm now I'm really rich."
That's it. People are like, "I can't get
a job." You're like, "I got the money,
[ __ ] I got it here."
Ever since I took Theo's workout plan,
everything been working out, man.
>> Yeah. I want to say
I studied with a Wookie.
That's right. Studied with a Wookie.
Wookie power. That's all I want. Wookie
power.
All right. Just from Python.
Hey Chewbacca. Hey Chewbaca.
Hey Chewbaca. Chewbaca.
Chewbacca is my wie. Chewbacca is my
wie.
Hey, there's class seven. We haven't
seen them for a long time.
What
are you doing?
So, let me see what you got, Joe. Joe,
hold on. Oh, look at what you got.
Good job, Joe.
Carlton, good job. Look at you guys.
Look, all you guys want to get money.
What you got, Logan?
Do let me look at this. Logan.
Wow.
No, I like it.
Okay.
>> 57.
I said 50 57.
Did I not
guys were telling your grandchildren one
time? I I started this new career
learning it from this black man who
spoke to me in Japanese with a bookie.
>> I didn't understand what the hell he was
saying, but I got the job anyway.
>> Theo, you might end up in an anime.
>> Yeah,
probably eventually.
This guy going around throwing Cisco
router systems.
How dare
Okay. Uh, who's this? Joe. Good job.
Like what I see. Let's see. We got
Kevin.
Okay.
Smith there. And then we got over here.
Good Kevin. Good job. Wow. You guys
really learned a lot after Armageddon.
You guys are like totally different
students.
I see that the survivors have skills,
survival skills. I like this.
You guys can work on this. It's easy.
You're following instructions.
Wow.
No, Carlton, you may not want the
Japanese money, but you want the
Japanese booty. I'm just saying.
Okay, William,
what do you got, William? Let's go look
at this real quick.
Good. Good job, William. You got David.
Wow, David. Wow, look at you, David.
Um, let's see there. What do you got?
Peria?
Really?
>> Yeah.
You don't want to be in the city.
I know what you're talking about.
Okay, I'll take it.
>> But but let that be known that you are
known in Perio. So
>> I like being known in Peria.
>> Right. Right.
like it.
All right, hold up.
Um,
that's right. I want that Japanese bento
box, too. Been a while.
So, if it says hello bashcloud, it says
hello unknown from Python. It means
you're not actually running this the the
new script. So, you haven't you haven't
invoked it yet. Okay.
Yeah. Same thing for uh Jode. You
haven't invoked the script yet.
So, why don't we do this um Python crop?
Whoa. Wow. I'm I'm the only one share
screen. Um JSON uh Bashcript. Why don't
you go ahead and share your screen and
then the guys will walk you through
this.
JavaScript.
While while we're waiting, what do you
think um how you how you think uh Japan
addressing their um their work crisis?
How do you think they're handling it?
Cuz right cuz right now they say we want
workers, we don't want immigrants. And
it's understandable, but what's your
opinion?
>> That's very Japanese. They're doing an
entirely Japanese right there. This is
no joke.
>> This is how they are.
>> Okay.
>> They they are not playing around.
>> So, for the most part, their immigration
policy is they only want college
educated people coming over.
>> Yeah.
>> And only to work.
>> And then if you're a man, you were to
find one of their women and give her
some DNA. the Japanese people got more
variety in in DNA
>> informally. They're saying that.
>> No, it's not. Well,
>> if the the the the man part is informal,
but the for the former what are they
then like they want foreigners to come
over and work for sure, but I
unless unless I'm to believe what IP is
telling you. They're not paying dudes to
come over and bang chicks out and then
have kids. Oh, no. They they they
definitely don't want that. Cuz
>> that's what I'm saying.
>> Want is you to have a job
>> and then
>> to create a family
>> to create a family and then you give
your salary to the Japanese woman,
>> right?
>> A stipen and she controls everything,
but you you make kids with her.
>> That's what they want. They want the
stability. So they definitely want like
a middle class biracial child to go to
school.
That's their big thing.
>> Yeah. But so they're looking for
suckers.
>> I'm not and I'm not trying to down what
Japan is doing, but like the Japanese
dudes already bowed out of that
contract. Now they now they want other
guys to go into the that same contract
that Japanese dudes don't want to follow
up.
>> Yes. Yes. They want they
They've had this policy, this this idea
since the 19th century,
>> never stopped. Even during World War II,
they still wanted like biracial kids.
They might have discrimination or some
issue with them, but they're they they
still wanted.
So, it's it's kind of like, you know,
how the prime minister is going around
saying only like only Japanese
foreigners bad, right?
>> Yeah.
>> Who's who's she taking photos with? an
English rock heavy metal band.
>> True.
>> Right. So th that's if you if you're a
Japanese observer, you know what this is
saying. This is saying it's like, "Okay,
you have to be Japanese. We want the
assistant. We want the westerners to
come over with their skill set. Oh, and
by the way, we'll party with you and
we'll [ __ ] your brains out,
>> right?
>> But after that, we expect you to be
Japanese.
>> You can go do you could do sake. could
do like all this kind of stuff. We want
your DNA, but you're going to do things
[ __ ] Japanese here.
>> That's that's how they are.
>> That that's that's understood. Totally
fine cuz that's that's you play what you
play the rules of the court you're on.
That's fine. Not a problem. House rules.
But all I'm saying is um or well better
yet my question is my question was more
so do you do you from your international
contacts or from your contacts in Japan
do you see guys signing up to do those
new new immigrants new people coming
into the country to do those roles
because because there's also a ground
swell of of of anti-forigner sentiment
on the on the on the from from people on
on a grassroots basis. But I get why
that's also the case.
>> Okay. So, this is class-based.
So,
>> anything
I would say
if you're above
$80,000 and above, didn't have a problem
with you.
>> 8,000 US.
>> Yeah. Or it would be 8 million yand
here.
Oh, dude.
>> If you're if you're 8 million, you're
double what the regular guy makes in
Japan because the regular guy is
supposed to make three a year.
>> Yeah. Yeah. So, if you're if you're at 8
million, which if you're working in it
in Japan, it's really easy to get to 8
million. So, if you're 8 million and
you're with one of the women, perfect.
because
the woman actually gets a a guy who is
making more money than the locals and so
she's more likely to breed. Oh,
>> so that's good. And so they're happy
with that. And then you can be paying
taxes. As long as you follow the
Japanese system, they're good. When
they're when they're talking about
foreigners, they don't like I know what
this is. This is 3 million yen and
below.
>> They're they're they're they're going
after those guys. So
>> content creators.
>> Well, I mean, if you're they don't care
about content creator so much, but like
if you're Thai and you're you're working
at Kini
and you're not like a student, students,
they don't care. They're like, "Cool,
you're a student here. We we got you."
>> But if you're like Thai and you're
competing with local Japanese labor for
Kini job,
they're not going to like you
>> or O job, something like that.
>> And you're like, I'll I'll work for like
150,000 yen a month and the Japanese
girl is making 200,000. Okay, now we
hate you. Yeah, there there was some
real hatred because that they have to
there's price competition. Uh so that's
when the Japanese were saying, "Hey, the
foreigners are ruining our salaries and
because of this kind of situation."
>> Oh, so basically on the low end, the
foreigners are taking the job. Okay.
Yeah. Oh, similar to the Indian thing
where they're students, but they're
working at
>> uh the Bies or the 7-Eleven,
>> right? So, what what they want is
something like Okay. like one of my
students, I forgot his name, but he was
at 8 million yen a year. Now he's at 10
million yen. So what they would want is
a Japanese person who can compete with
him and then he can maybe make 7 million
yen a year. So then we have a higher
trained Japanese man who can replace a
foreigner that can do the same thing but
for less.
>> Yeah.
>> And then that guy can go and get a
Japanese girl then and breed and make a
family. That's that's how they would
think. That would be the best way of
doing it,
>> right? So they still want to be
competitive with a foreigner, but they
for the benefit of Japanese men. When
poorer foreigners come in and they make
poor Japanese have to do competition,
they're like, "Get the katanas out.
Just let's just go to the street right
now and pour the blood out. We'll kill
them right now." They're not playing.
They will do it too.
>> And and and I'll say this last week and
yes, Nigerians are also a part of that
negative stereotype. They stay they stay
in um uh what's the what's the what's
the red light district?
>> Oh yeah, that isn't it like the party
area because I remember there there was
a big thing cuz they one of them punched
an American a couple months ago.
>> Yeah. American or an American, European
or um or maybe like um a dude from
Australia, but yeah, Nigerian.
>> This one I'm thinking of he's defin he's
he does like some content in Japan, but
he's like lived there a while, but he's
American and
>> Okay.
>> And he went back and ended up like
recording them and there's like they
found a bunch of like prostitution and
stuff ran by the Nigerians. It wasn't a
good look.
>> Yep. Yep. that I I can't help my people,
man. They're going they're going crazy
worldwide.
>> Now, when people ask, "Rub, you're
you're you're just strictly American."
You're like, "Where is Nigeria? Never
heard of it."
>> I can't I can't do that. I can't do
that.
>> Can't do that.
>> So, let me let me just comment on here.
The reason why they wouldn't want the
Nigerians to be involved in prostitution
is because they want the Japanese Yakuza
to be involved in and actually maintain
that market.
>> So somebody is encouching on a Yakuza
market. They're going to get exed.
That's the way that gate works. All
right. So the Nigerians should have
known better. They should have been
employed by the Yakuza. Then the Aqua
would have been cool with them. They my
guess is that they most likely are when
the um Oh my god, I'm blanking on the
name of the red light district.
>> They would they would not have arrested
them. Cousin Rapungi.
>> Thank you.
>> Rapungi, that's where most of the
Nigerians were were offering sexual
things like that. But
>> like I always looked out cuz I was like
this the only area every other area like
this in in Tokyo the Yakuza are
involved. So either they the Nigerians
were offering something different or
they were encouraging on Yakuza's face
and that usually ends with people
disappearing.
>> Not smart.
>> I my suspicion well you know what
doesn't matter about my suspicion. Uh
Bash is sharing screen. He's going to do
his notes. So sorry for
>> people people help help Bash out.
>> Yeah.
How about Bash? Let me complain to look
at this real quick. Looking at you, TK.
Good. Tiqs. Very good. Yay.
Tiqs getting that money.
>> They want the money. Ask
one more question.
>> Um, Roongi, Nigerians aren't ruining
Roongi. That's impossible.
before ever started ruining the rapongi
uh the police would just come out and
say hi
>> we have a hotel cell for you
>> the Niger the Nigerians in my opinion is
more so just a buoant it's more so just
a very visible symptom of what's
happening because the question then
becomes how are these
foreigners allowed to operate in this
space who's allowing this and that
that's why I think, you know, it's still
Yakuza behind it, but
but there's enough Nigerian middlemen in
to make it to make it work. So, is it
just looks like it's Nigerian and like
other Africans who may be there, but
ultimately
can't help it. Can't help it that the
face is Nigerian, but I I think that
there's more behind it, but I can't
really prove it. So, got to take it down
the chin.
>> Oh, the the thing I was thinking was it
was in uh
Shinjuku and then party area here.
>> Yeah.
>> Uh different. I mean, unless it's maybe
a certain part of it. I I'll just put
the videos in the chat.
>> Lonnie, very good. Very good screenshot.
I like that documentation, Lonnie. You
did a great job.
Python.
>> Oh, no. Kabuki Cho. Yeah. Yeah.
>> What's the other one?
>> Kabuki Cho. There were definitely
foreigners working there and they were
under Yakuza control.
And Kabuki Cho. I've I've taken you guys
through there virtually during the day
like with Google Maps. You have to be
very careful about what you're doing
there. You need to be aware
because there are Yakuza there like real
Yakuza and they're watching you. So as
long as you are you're cool everything
is correct.
Oh well there's not a question then.
How come do you anticipate more Hoos
coming from Okinawa up to the mainland?
>> No.
But the but those are the people that
that that Japanese people want at the
very least they well they're they have
mixed
they're mixed to an extent and no
um
so
the Japanese don't necessarily entirely
think of Okinawa as being Japanese.
>> Oh, okay.
>> It's kind It's kind of like a colony
concept. So, if they're doing Hau there,
they're like, "Okay,
>> it's it's
the way they want Hau is, I mean, just
to be just to be honest, their daughter
marries an American, Canadian, English,
or Frenchman
and gets pounded out by him and they
make kids. That's a good one.
>> Let's go, Aaron.
>> And you do you not count American
anymore?
>> The fact that your name is Nigerian,
they don't give a [ __ ] They're like,
"Is your passport
US? Were you
>> passport?" Oh,
>> you're American.
>> They don't have enough They don't have
enough time to think about
like something like something else. So
like we're like we're like America's a
country of immigrants. We get it. Are
you American? Yes or no? So they would
like like
an EK or Yeah. EK. So a first generation
Japanese person and you are the same in
their eyes.
>> Damn.
>> You're both American. You're not
Japanese.
>> Okay.
>> That's all they think.
Do they look at them like secondass
citizens? They wouldn't, Larry. They
wouldn't look at them as secondass
citizens. They would look at them as a
little exotic though.
>> That's different.
>> Yeah, cuz there's
>> a lot of singers come from Okina,
but it's not
not entirely the same. The same thing
with um Hokkaido, but not as bad like
the Inu.
Hey my people,
shout out to the I knew man.
>> Hold on, hold on. So Erin, you would
clean up, but tiqs, you would also clean
up,
>> right?
Cuz you got that blue passport.
Yeah, let me
>> you got you got you gota get you gota
coach up IP deal.
>> I I I I don't know what to do with IP
right now.
>> Um something happened again.
>> Jerome, very good guys. You guys do the
NodeJS also. You guys, a lot of guys are
doing the Python only. Go to Node.js. Do
that one too.
>> They're they're both equally
>> important
>> as easy. I was gonna say it's easier.
>> They're both easy. Yep.
>> Yeah.
>> Like
with the Python one, you know, you got
to change the runtime to Python. You
have to do one extra click. With the
node one, you have to rename the file
type.
About the same.
>> About the same.
Erin,
if you went there as a cloud engineer,
>> give him a g give them how much? 120,
130, 150. What's the price range we're
working with?
If just
>> just come on just what
>> just if you were like just 10 million
yen a year
>> just just
>> that's
think of it like you think about buying
power. So 8 million is roughly
>> 10 million yen would it would convert to
like 60 grand right now.
>> No don't look at the current exchange
rate. Everybody uses a h 100red yen to
the dollar as the exchange rate in terms
of p purchasing power parody which which
is actually correct. So if you're making
$100,000 a year or $80,000 a year in
Japan in Tokyo, you're made you're good.
So if you're a cloud engineer, if anyone
say anyone in this class, okay,
if you have a business card, you're a
cloud engineer, you're kind of nerdy,
geeky, you got a date.
Done.
It's simple.
It's very simple process.
We got Jerome.
Jerome, good. I like it. I like it,
Jerome.
Okay.
See couchi. Couchi. Very good. You did
both of them.
Say Logan. Good. Logan.
I I Yeah, it's
I'm having very complex feelings with
Japan right now. It's hard. I I had to
figure this out. It's like so what? What
are you doing?
Did you make a kid today? Did you try?
Uh Logan, good. No, Michael. Good.
>> Got make sure got make sure your knees
are good, deal,
>> they're not good, actually. They're
really sucky.
>> Do that. Do some medical tourism first.
Uh, Michael. Very good. Like what I see,
Michael.
Oh, no. Hold on. What do you got here,
Rob?
>> No. No. That's distracting the class.
Come on.
>> No. No. No. No. We're not doing that.
We're talking about Japanese women. Not
that.
>> See, I'm I just told you I'm that
distracted. And you still open it. What
are you doing? I told you no.
>> Like I insist.
>> See? Oh, now I get the I get the tech.
Come on, man. Come on, man.
Come on.
What? I told you don't do it.
>> Hold on. I have something for Rob. I
think uh Theo's thinking right now.
>> Let's do it.
So when I was making I was making 25
million yen a year for AWS before two
years ago. If I would have gone to Japan
with that and had the business card and
would that I I could have like picked up
16 and 18 year olds.
>> I would never have done that. I'm just
saying that would have been an option.
>> You can you can pick you can pick up
grandma, wives, anyone.
Pick up your balls.
>> Pick up the whole family. Like the the
the ma the mom, the daughter, the and
the aunties. All right.
>> Yeah. You get them all.
>> Just just f find me find me the aunties
with the uh the Kai. I'm with I'm with
it.
>> They Yeah. Yeah.
>> They're out there.
>> You could like sister her sister like
Okay. Anyway, um, yeah,
>> why are you typing in?
>> Hold on.
>> Because Max Max challenge
>> practice.
>> I'm
Wait, you what? YOU DID WHAT? WHO?
Somebody typed it in. Are you cuckoo? I
put it there as a copy ofable thing for
a reason.
J Hall. Good. So, J Oh, sorry. Be hole.
You did that one correct. Um, let's do
the the nojs. Maybe you did it, but
let's get both get them both in there.
>> That's easy. Yeah, I did them both.
>> Talking about practice, man. About that
talking about that practice.
>> Don't worry, Larry. Behold, kiss me
honest on them on them chica. So, don't
worry about that,
>> Joe. Yes, sir.
>> Joe, you did a great job.
>> I just I just want to keep I just want
you to keep your head on the swivel,
right? You know, I know Aaron is here.
So, you know, I'm right behind you when
you start veering off, you know. So, you
know me.
>> Well, you're supposed to be getting the
job, man. What you talking about?
>> I'm I'm trying to do that, too. I can do
two things at once.
>> Oh, you can walk and chew bubble gum.
Okay, I see you.
>> Yes.
>> A Renaissance man walk and chew bubble
gum. Look at Look at God. Look, look at
Larry. There you go. There you go, big
baby.
>> You do well in Japan, Larry. Just
saying.
>> Oh, we know. But he's like, I can't do
that. I I need I need I need more booty.
>> Yes.
>> How about less booty, but emotional
temperament regulation in the
relationship?
>> I like Aaron, too. So, Aaron is Aaron's
uh
>> Did you just say you want my
Larry.
>> Oh boy.
>> Wait. Hey, Jay asked if he missed the uh
Oblock screenshot. So, can another
screenshot from Old Block?
>> No, I I I made a boo boo. I watched the
weekend's class and
I needed to watch last Tuesday's class,
so I have to go.
>> What? What do you mean? This This has
nothing to do last.
>> Aren't you class six?
>> Yes, I am. I This is the first time
you've seen lambda.
>> I haven't. No. But this here is
>> You could just follow the instructions.
>> You can just follow the instructions.
>> I wanted I I like to review first before
doing it. I like to take notes. And
that's what I'm
Stop it. Stop it.
Okay. You share your screen, Oblak. And
you guys walk him through this. I want
to make sure he gets this.
>> I I I didn't do I didn't review
Tuesday's class. I did Saturday's
Saturday. Saturday and Sunday are the
same class. The same class.
>> It doesn't matter. It doesn't matter for
No, no, no, no, no, no. It does not
matter. This is my repo.
>> What you did last week was introduction.
Are you Are you done in front of a
screen?
>> Oh [ __ ]
in front of the screen.
>> Are you in front of the computer?
>> Yes, I am.
>> Oh,
>> okay. All right. Are you presentable? Is
there a Kha there in your house?
>> Oh, she is a key there smoking smoking a
black and mild. What you doing over
there, Larry?
>> I'm I'm fine. It's just I was just, you
know, taking notes and reviewing the
class and I got Tuesday's class. I asked
a couple of my buddies in class and
today's class is more in line with
Tuesdays instead of the weekends. So, I
wanted to watch the Tuesday class first
and then you know
>> Saturday's class was easy. Rob did the
class and that was easy. I saw that
before and Sunday was kind of weird.
>> Hold on, hold on, hold on, hold on, hold
on. Is anybody living in Chicago right
now?
>> Is anybody in Chicago
besides besides Larry? Is anybody
besides Larry in Chicago?
>> Pretty pretty close.
>> Okay. Can you drive over there and kill
Larry?
>> Not Logan. Logan, that's my buddy from
class 6. I don't I have a lot of uh
>> I can pay. He's He No, Logan. No. No. Me
and
>> a nice reference for your job.
>> I give you a nice reference. I I get my
connections.
>> You just go there right now. Would you
like that? Can you just do take care of
this? No, Logan.
>> Larry, Larry, you know better.
>> I'll drive over there and help him share
a screen.
>> Oh my goodness.
>> Oh, yeah. Share something. Yeah.
>> Okay.
>> Um I don't know, Larry. You know the
rules. Um Okay, I'm gonna let that one
go. Hold on.
>> Okay.
>> But we This didn't have any relation to
what we did on Monday. That was just
introduction. This was this is a
different kind of a different
environment. So I'm using API gateway.
Uh okay. Good. Okay. Carlton very good.
We got Michael
very good.
We like
Okay. Hall. Good. Be hall. Very good.
Carlton. Boom. Boom. Joel. What the ch
Okay,
relax
therapy. We all good.
Hold on. I know you can't find nice half
of it. Maybe half Thai, half or half
Brazil. Okay,
>> so the issue
>> with hau gonna say this real quick. The
issue with hau guys in Japan is that
everyone wants to bang them.
>> Yep.
>> Everyone.
And they know it. So your competition
level is massive.
>> So I just I don't I don't even care
>> because you can date a Japanese normal
Japanese girl and not everyone is trying
to bang her and she's just happy you're
paying attention to her. Listen,
>> you're gonna do by far better with her.
>> You know, a come up, if you guys want
the real come up, right, treat a
Japanese chick like you treat a uh a uh
Dominican chick. You you you get you get
her first,
take her out of the country, take her
out of the country, go somewhere else,
third place, and then you fix your
teeth. Game over.
>> Rob knows.
Am
I right?
>> I bet that they think it's cute.
>> No, the braces during like your 20s and
30s. That's a That's awesome. I love it
because they're finally trying to fix
their teeth. Like
the deal's conflicted.
I'm still c I'm still catching highs
from when Theo and I think uh Tel was
talking about how if you get married to
one of them the magical steel and that
really haunts me you know about you know
Japanese
>> see that that's when you're in her
environment
>> and but that's how she's also trained.
>> Hold on. Very good. Uh Erin okay we're
go Aaron went to the next part so let's
go over to the next part. Um, yeah. You
I just You get used to the teeth thing.
It's They think it's beautiful and and
cute, so you you just don't look
>> Oh, okay. Okay. I My bad. I didn't I
Okay, cool.
>> Well, it's a first world country. I
mean, surely it's not like it's a lack
of money or anything. It Yeah, it's just
uh which I mean, arguably it it's kind
of nice. It's like you don't have to
worry about having perfect teeth which
really isn't from a functional you at
least usually functionally not
important.
>> Fair enough.
>> Slightly better than in like Thailand
where they just wear fake ones to look
cute.
>> They wear veneers out in Thailand.
>> No, braces. Fake braces.
>> They wear fake brace. Really?
>> Yeah. I think in like I think in just
Southeast Asia in general, but it's it's
really popular in Thailand.
>> Okay. So, small small point, not that
many people can wear braces in Thailand.
It's kind of expensive. So, if you have
braces, it's a status symbol.
So, that's why the girls wear it to show
that they have money.
>> That's crazy.
>> Okay. So, uh let's go through the API
gateway um walk through.
Okay. First,
okay, so first thing I want you to do
again here is um create let's see who's
going to share their screen today. Who
who should uh Kirk, you do it. Think
you're you're doing good before going
and have you share your screen. Okay.
And
>> all right. What we doing?
>> API gateway. Um, who else do I want to
share the screen? Lonnie, you did a
really good job. Lonnie, you want to
share your screen?
Okay, so Kirk is sharing. Good. Okay, I
need you to go to I put the link into
the chat. Go into lab a just uh Kirk
just go two levels up from where you're
at right now. Uh, so go to lab. No, no,
no. Keep go down. Down. Lab a API lab a
API gateway. Up. Yeah, there.
>> Are we still in this directory here?
>> Yeah. Look, I said API. You can read.
>> No, you have so much. I I was wondering
if I was in another directory or what.
>> You're fine.
>> It's all same.
>> All right. Okay. So, what you're going
to be doing here is No, you you I I can
share my instructions. You have to go to
your prompt. Go to go
>> go to your console.
>> Go to your console
now. Go to API. Type in the search API
gateway.
>> I got another Lonnie, you sharing your
screen.
Okay. So, we're going to do here is
we're going to do create API. Good.
There. And then what do you Well, hold
on. Create API.
>> Choose uh HTTP API now. There you go.
Yep. Build.
There you go. And API name. Then uh
navigate.
Uh hold on. API name.
Uh, hold on. Integration.
>> Integr. He needs to add two
integrations.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So, add integration. Add
integration.
>> Just stay in the console.
>> Okay.
>> All right. I won't flip.
>> So, so a API gateway is is so it's sort
of like for lambda, although it does
more than this. It's kind of like a load
balancer, but it has lots of other
features. And so, we're
>> Yeah. Can it like throttle it?
>> Yeah, it can do it can charge people for
using it. It can do lots of different
things, but it can also split traffic
between different backends. So you might
have like some lambdas, some a
Kubernetes cluster, some EC2s with their
own load balancer and stuff and it can
decide where to send stuff. So you're
going to send stuff split it to two
different uh backends and those are
called integrations.
>> So in the integration I see oh you see
how has it has a drop down
click on the drop down section.
Okay you got click on lambda
lambda click on lambda lambda up there.
Okay so then make sure the right region.
>> Yeah that's my default. Yeah.
>> No. So change your Okay. Okay. So then
lambda function. Click on there.
There. Which one you going to do?
>> Let's do the we get notes from the
>> This is why the naming convention was
there because it should say two button.
Okay. Next. You're going to do add
integration.
>> No. Go back.
>> Add integration.
Lambda.
You have two lambdas.
Oh, the other one was a different class.
This one was Python and that one's null
here.
>> Well, the ones you
>> did today, the two you did today. Do
them both.
>> Yep. It's it's the Python here. I named
them based off the the code.
>> Okay, there you go.
All right.
>> You want me to click next?
>> Yep. And next.
I'm going do roots routes add there.
Okay. So method hold on hold on. Method
is going to be get
resource path. First one's going to be
slash python.
Okay. And again this is all the
instructions you guys will watch me do
this my screen integration target. Which
lambda's got to is that going to go to?
There you go. Next one. Hold on. Stop.
Stop. You can go. Go to the method part
of the line. Second line.
>> No. Stop.
>> Method.
>> Go to the method. Method. Go to the
left. Method man. Method man. Method.
>> Drop. Where you put the get? Where you
put the get? Um, Kirk.
>> Yeah, you have to do it again.
Get
me. Okay. All right. All right.
Now resource path. Look at my look at my
screen. You have to ask to be slashnode.
I got this all spelled out for you. Now
integration target. What is it going to
be?
>> There you go.
>> My no function.
Good lord.
>> Okay. So go to next.
Okay. Define stage should be correct. Uh
name prod. Name it Bob.
>> Do you want this dollar sign or just
like that?
>> There you go. And uh do next.
Everything looks good. Okay. Good.
Create.
So stages is probably it that's for like
AB testing or blue green deployments and
stuff, right? Like where you could copy
the
>> That's what I thought. So I didn't know
like I was like kind of guessing to
that.
>> But you mean you can name it your mama
doesn't just saying.
>> Okay.
Okay. So
deploy.
>> Okay.
>> It uh should already have deployed. This
is for a separate deployment.
>> Oh, that's right. That's right. Okay.
Click out of there. Cancel.
>> Okay. So, where Okay, there is
>> Yeah. Uh you see right up here.
>> There it is. Okay. There it is. Go over
there and get your That's your path.
There you go. So that's invoked URL.
Good. Click on that
>> or there. Yeah. Yeah. Down here. It's
just Yeah. This will have the deployment
on it.
>> Oh, I see. Okay.
>> Okay. So,
it did not deploy
>> it. No. No. No. He didn't put the query
uh string.
>> Oh, that's right. He didn't do it then.
Yeah.
Um,
>> so go back to the pa the browser page.
>> Yeah, correct.
>> Okay.
>> So, do you remember how we did the test
uh invocations and we gave it a query
parameter uh in the JSON, right?
>> Yeah.
So that was to load like to give it to
the API endpoint that the lambda is
running. So no good go keep stay in your
web browser. So to do that same thing
but this time in the URL we do question
mark for query parameter
and then the name of our query parameter
which is name.
So name
>> so we called it name
>> equals
and then whatever you want the value to
be. So like malgus was the what the
example was.
>> So we can do
>> enter.
think it did anything.
>> Oh, he's missing still the end point. Uh
he doesn't have node or uh Python on
there
it should be
>> oh on the uh query.
>> So it should be forward like slashpro
because that so like up to here
this is your API endpoint.
But then
>> so we got to point it to
>> then you need your you would need to add
your route
>> right. So that would be
>> and then
>> you add the
query.
>> Oh okay
>> parameter
set and then
AP
>> that makes sense.
end point.
So yeah, when we're thinking of like the
URL, it's going to be in three parts.
One, two, three.
Yeah, that makes sense. Oh, that's how I
uh I was messing with your metadata,
Theo, when I put on my dashboard. I have
to do something like this. That That
makes sense.
Enter.
>> So, this one should Yeah, there we go.
Okay.
>> Now, next one I want you to do. Hold on.
Stop there. Take a screenshot. Take a
screenshot of that. Put that in your
notes.
>> All right. The next to do is
well go to your URL
replace node with Python
and then replace Nate replace Malcus
with Chewbacca.
There you go.
Very good.
We got Lonnie.
Okay, let's help Lonnie out. Same thing.
I got Lonnie.
Oh, Lonnie. Good.
That's interesting.
Interesting.
Oh, Lonnie, you know what you're doing.
Very advanced.
>> I'm impressed.
>> Really?
>> Put your API uh end points in the chat
when you guys get them done.
Yep.
Yeah. Put that strip.
Hold on. So, I got J.
Very good.
J again.
Python. Yes, Chewbacca does love. Uh,
Chewbacca loves porks.
There's the only good thing about that
episode 8, Chebacca eating porks. I was
all I was down to that.
There you go. All right, Kevin. Very
good. Well, you guys, man, you guys are
really on another level now.
Good. Look at that. Look.
Look at you guys not using Oh, wow.
comes and I'm impressed. Daniel, very
good, Daniel. Wow.
Wow. Lonnie,
good. Very good, Lonnie.
The next one. Ah, there you go. Look at
that. Wow. This is getting This is too
easy for you, Jay. Good. Good. Okay,
Jay.
Joe,
look at you guys are Man, you guys all
want jobs.
I can't believe these guys. You guys,
you know, just yesterday, you guys did
no [ __ ] Now you guys are all doing
this. Oh my goodness. You guys, we keep
on teaching you and keep on growing. I I
We can't put you into CompTIA jobs
anymore. What are we going to do with
you now? Okay, Kevin. Good job. Wow,
Kevin. Oh, look at that. Me likey bash.
Oh, there you go. I like it. Bash.
I'm bashful about Bash. Good. Yeah,
Logan. Oh, look at that.
Oh, very good. Larry doesn't want to
submit because he's too busy with Kha.
No block. He wants to stay there with
her. Okay, Joe. Very good. Look at like
this, Joe. You're like, like a doggy.
Good job, Joe. So, how do you use a
domain for the API? DNS. Yes, JJ is is
that's going to be for later. Okay. Not
for now. What for later? Yeah, we're
doing that. Uh, BashCloud.
Good.
Okay. I'm embarrassed. Uh, why are you
embarrassed? What, Larry? Why you embar
No, you're not. You're an SAA. You ain't
no You ain't no embarrassed. Stop that.
Eat. Heat. That's okay. He doesn't
doesn't want the doesn't want the bunda.
It's all right. More bunda for you,
Theo.
>> That's more bunda for me. Hello. Big
booty Latina from No. Jay got the big
booty Latina. I like it.
>> Larry ought to share his screen. Larry
ought to share his screen.
>> No. No. Larry doesn't want the big booty
Latina. He doesn't want it. He doesn't
want He want the big booty. Kesha, size
16.
Four.
Four babies from three guys. They're all
locked up in Juliet.
Does know where the money's coming from.
That's what he wants.
>> Tiqs
wants to share his screen.
>> Okay, go ahead and share your screen.
Tiqs, you're sharing.
Multiple people can share screen.
Kirk, uh Kirk, you got yours all good,
right?
Yeah, mine's fine. All right.
>> Yeah, Kirk. Kirk, you're rocking it. I
like it.
>> Wow.
>> Hey, it looks like you might have gotten
this.
So, no, no, go back to go back up here.
Okay, so this is your this is your end
point. So you take that
and then make a new tab.
>> Yeah, there it is. Hit enter.
>> Yeah.
>> No,
>> yep. Yeah, that should be correct. Enter
prod.
>> No, he doesn't have
>> Well, he doesn't have his he doesn't
have his uh like back end.
>> Yeah, you need to put Python
>> Yeah, there you go.
>> Yep.
>> Yep. Do fine. There you go.
There you go.
Then just you know what to do for the
next one.
There you go.
That'll work. Yeah. There you go. There.
See? Is that easy?
>> Yeah. I just had a bot.
I had copied and pasted the wrong link.
No, no, you're you're fine. You just
didn't go to the directory. That's good.
>> Up right here. My bad.
>> No, you're fine. Who is this?
Ah,
yeah, that's that's cloud money and
going to the gym. There you go. That
That's good. I I'll take that. Oh, you
got goals. That reminds me of a Afro
Venezuelan I I met one time.
>> Don't like you.
>> Like that.
>> I I don't I do not like you.
>> You like the twist of my
>> She was kind of caramel chocolatey like
that. More chocolate than caramel to be
honest.
>> This guy
where where's Go eat your borch steel.
Leave the caramel alone.
You know, if I could just figure out a
decent place to put the gym in Colombia,
it's probably going to be Columbia.
I know what version one of the gym is
going to be right now. So, yeah.
>> Well, this is good. She's really
>> She's nice. That's That's very good. I
I'll take that.
>> This guy.
>> Oh, that that is exquisite. Okay. Ah,
good taste. Good taste. Okay. So, there
you go. Note, they got TIQS. Yes. Very
good. Yes. TIQS. Good. Yeah.
Stink. Stink. Guinness. I don't call
stank.
>> Guinness is culture.
>> Guinness is a way of life outside the
states, man. Don't do that.
>> Yeah. Don't Don't be messing with
Guinness, man. Kill Kenny and Guinness.
That's how I learn to drink. All right.
I didn't do no like cheap ass beer. It
was it was Guinness.
Good old good old uh Irish or like oh
Theo, you don't drink. We're gonna end
that right now.
I'm innocent. I don't want to drink. You
don't drink now, [ __ ] So started
drinking.
>> Oh, good memories.
Yo, I really want you to try that shade
I told you about since class.
>> We would like you we would like you to
pull up a API gateway, but we can't all
get what we want now, can we?
>> This tomorrow and I'll try to do one for
for this weekend.
>> Okay, so Saturday you're coming in class
and you're doing this. Okay, especially
if I'm teaching, okay, I'll be ready.
>> But my admins are here, so they're going
to be doing that too with you. So I
might be the other class. I'll be ready.
I'll be ready.
>> I I I I have full confidence you will be
there.
>> Or else I might be taking the flight
over to Chicago and I'll be down the
street.
>> Oh, you come here. Oh, you know, I get
my goon squad. Hey, somebody's coming
in. Uh
>> he's near and dear to my heart, but
sometimes he's talking.
>> I hire him. I got money.
>> I I'll just go say whatever he's paying,
I'll pay it double. Boom. Done.
>> You don't smoke, you remember. So, uh, I
think I might have a little bit over
you.
>> It's all right.
>> I like smoking. Actually,
>> we got to put her in the gym. Deal.
>> Who's Who's this?
>> Central Asia.
>> Seems like it.
>> Yeah. Tate of Truth. I like her more.
>> Really?
>> Yeah. The T of Truth. Mookie Mookie
would go with this faster.
I like I like her I like her energy.
She Well, that would be that would be a
great addition to the uh conclave. You
know what I mean?
>> That's That's true.
>> Walking in with something like that like
Yeah. She's going to be um handling
people walking into the conclave. Yeah.
>> With with with Sh with Shan's with
Shan's lady.
>> Yeah. With Shan's lady. Oh, yeah. That'd
be great.
But she is Oh, that's Russian.
Oh, that's not necessarily Russian. No,
that's not Russian.
That's another language. I can read it.
>> Greek. I know the Mongolian script isn't
Some of it's like not too
>> That might speak Mongolian.
>> Yeah, that might be Mongolian.
>> Hold on. Let me see.
Grock, is this Mongolian?
>> It's actually chat GPT, but like I said,
I I just call them all Grock.
>> Uh, well, I for me, I need it.
>> I I might be incorrect, but doesn't the
Mongolian language uh originally stem
from uh uh
uh Islamic uh uh uh uh wagers?
>> It does. it the script and the language
two different worlds.
>> Well, I I understand that, but I don't
think
>> I don't Mongolian.
>> Yeah,
>> it's Mongolian, right?
>> Yeah, Mongolian.
>> Yeah. Yeah, that's why I thought it
Yeah, cuz I was I was I was going
through here. I was like, no, it's not
Russian, man. There just too many
characters that are not Russian. I can
read it, though. I mean, I know what's
going on. It's
>> Yeah, registration's now open.
a single lesson. 80 minutes.
>> 80 minutes is a long time. I don't know
if the would last.
>> I was thinking like southern Russia then
like
the the Mongol. Yeah, she's Mongolian.
Yeah, they're nuts. They're they're fun.
>> Yeah, I've I've known I knew Mongolians
in uh Japan. Oh boy, those people were
fun.
They could drink. My I thought Japanese
women could drink. Wow. Mongolian women
could knock it down, man. They're good.
All right. Anyway, okay.
So, we got that.
Uh I think you guys did this section
correctly. You guys did it good. All
right. Um
>> well have people talk about the checks
because that's the speech talks about
it. Do a lab but you can't talk about
it. That's that's that's half the lab
you got to talk about.
>> Okay. So we have we created the API
gateway. Why did we create the API
gateway? So what's going on?
Is that like a u
I don't know if it's quite a reverse
proxy, but it does have like a load
balancing feature so you can uh route
traffic to different endpoints
essentially.
>> Yeah, the different lambdas. Uh Logan,
what you got?
>> Gives a an entry point for kind of
outside individuals access.
>> Correct.
>> Lambdas.
>> That's that's correct. So when you guys
had, you know, your on the VM, the EC2,
you put the user script on there, right?
People have direct access to your VM.
If you put it behind a load balancer,
they don't have direct access.
So what we did there is we put the EC2s
in the private subnet and then we use
the load balancers in public and we're
able to protect our infrastructure. The
API gateway, what it's going to do is
protect your code.
from people going directly against it
and then we can do all kinds of cool
stuff like rate limiting and things like
that. All right, so you guys did the
curl commands. I saw you guys doing the
logs. That's fine. Um,
that's fine. I don't think you guys I
think you guys get that part. Okay, so
this is good. I'm I'm pretty happy with
what you guys did.
This this is pretty good. Um, what you
guys should do to reinforce this is go
read BAGA everything with API and then
go reinforce this also with um um what's
his name? Stfan.
But to be honest, I wouldn't just do
Stafon with API gateway for the SAA. I
if there's a sale right now, there's
always a sale sometime. I would go into
the SAP and go take go do everything
with API gateway at the SAP level. All
right, you should reinforce this as as
fast as you possibly can.
All right, but to be honest with you,
you guys did really well. I'm actually
rather impressed. You guys have come a
long way. So,
good job students for learning. Good job
admins for teaching. Um, for you guys
who want homework, I think I can give
you guys some decent homework.
Uh, I want you to do WF right there.
Okay. So, please do WF and, uh, do the
lab section with the W and uh, submit so
that we know we just did that. But I
think you guys can do that Wing rather
well.
Now, for you guys who are really gung-ho
and you're like, "Fuck this [ __ ] man. I
ain't doing no click ops."
>> Well, it's called It's called to be be a
people who want to be a man. Be a man.
>> So, for you people who want to be a man,
uh, where's where's C?
There you go. You have lesson C.
I'm just saying if you want to do be a
man, there's some things in there,
right? I have no idea what any of this
stuff is. None. I I have no idea what a
TF file is.
>> Yeah. Just like just like you don't know
Japanese woman. Okay.
>> I have no idea Japanese women are. No, I
have no idea.
>> I thought what what language does
Chewbacca speak? It's outside outside of
Wookie. What language does he speak?
>> Creole. That's what he speaks. Trio.
>> He speaks Texan.
>> Where's Serge?
>> Yeah, I was about to say we need Serge.
>> He speaks Texan. That's it. He speaks
Texan.
>> That's it. That's all he needs. So, um,
>> Texan Creole.
>> Gotcha.
>> Zack P.
>> You have the You have the information
here for the Terraform to do this
section. If you guys want to do it all
in terraform, go for it. All right. Uh,
next week it's But I would say for your
homework, please do the W because then
next week I can do off uh OF2. So OF
zero and this is over here. Um,
right here I need we need to do a lab
from here in order to get the next
section done. And the next section is I
have part of it written here for the J
JWT token. And the JWT token is going to
be very important for you to have. So if
you can if you can do the automation,
have JWT token that means you can
protect the application with your API
gateway. That's money. Okay. What do you
got, Ryan? What do you got, man?
>> Ran. Man, I like this. All right. Um, I
suggest um
you got I would suggest reaching out to
um twins Gordon and and Dong cuz they
can do Octa and I know that that's going
to be coming up soon.
So, they can give you some insight on
that. BUT, OH, MY HAIR IS on fire.
>> How How do you know that I don't have an
octa lab ready?
>> Well, did you ask have you worked with
have you worked with people in the
question?
Have you worked with the people who are
certified in Octa yet?
>> How? Maybe I thought that two people are
already certified and I can include octa
then.
>> Have you worked with them?
>> I Okay, I got my answer. Thank you.
>> Maybe that's what I was thinking. I
don't know. Oh,
you and your AI admin, man, you guys are
tripped.
>> Yeah, my my AI admin did say, do you
want to add octa to this? I thought I
never thought about that. Yeah, I was
just going to do OOTH 2 authentication.
It's like, no, you should do off zero.
Why don't you do it that way? I was
like, okay, that sounds interesting. And
I was like, okay, well, those are the
the JWT, right? I I want to do something
else, but it's like, no, let's just do
JWT. That's what everybody uses. It's
easier to do it that way.
>> Other question other question is um um
what what's your thoughts on the on the
perspective, you know, AWS or GCP
trainer aspect of the potential, the
idea, the the pitch. Is that feasible?
Is it not? I'm going to go for it this
summer myself.
>> So, I think that's something that's a
value ad to give more legitimacy. Not
just that we have hundreds of guys
getting certified and we have over 100
guys with having jobs. No, now we'll get
the trainer. So, why not?
It just makes us stronger.
>> I I I would
Okay. I mean I
>> we have a black IT network like
>> Yes. Because you have like actual
because you have actual a network of
trainers that you you can say you have a
network of trainers
>> that are that you command let's say
>> and then okay
>> and they don't got [ __ ]
>> right but here but but my question of is
it feasible for let's say someone let's
say let's say the old block captain
right he decided to say you know what
you know what man I'm going to go out
there and I'm going to be a aw WS
trainer, man. I'mma train the I'mma
train the whole block. I'mma train the
whole old block on how to do AWS. Got my
SAA. I'm good to go, man. And then he
said, you know what, old block ain't
getting it. Let me go to
Santander. Let me go to Santander State
in Colombia. They they they see me
better. Is the Is that a feasible
entry way for someone to get abroad?
uh to get abroad. No. Uh be legit in
terms of a trainer. Yes. But the the
market like it be a cloud trainer,
you're not really going to get make that
much money in the market. It's not
>> Gotcha. Okay. So, this preemptive.
>> Yeah. But it it's nice to have it's nice
to have like just to be able to go to
other groups and say they don't know
[ __ ] Like really? That's not the
>> or if Gabe Bay is on
>> That's not the
>> CGS and then I have like 10 cloud
trainers going up against him.
>> Oh yeah.
>> Oh my god. That's not That's not All
right. My bad, Aaron. I I I I'm
endorsing bad behavior.
>> Oh no. I would like that. Then BTS and I
beating up Gabe. Oh,
I' I'd be in ecstasy over that.
>> I was just trying to
>> No, I could see it be like for corporate
trainings, but then you would have
probably do it if they want it in
person. So,
>> no, they they they also offer um uh
virtual, and that's that's what I was
thinking. You can get guys that could
speak a different language, get them
virtual,
>> put that much money abroad.
>> Yeah, that's
>> you're respected, but you're not taught
you're not you don't make money. that
that that's that's the only that's the
only uh drawback. So,
>> at least internally, although like the
AWS one, it's like easy in theory, but
it is like a multi-day in-person exam
where you have to like go through their
curriculum and like uh with evaluators
and stuff, but if you can get past that,
you can get like uh free vouchers for
your students and get them all free
credits and stuff.
>> Exactly. And that that's what I was
looking at like, hey, there's some
feature ads here that could be nice
because, you know, shout out to Remo.
Remo got his uh Microsoft trainer and
Casey's a Microsoft trainer. So, I'm
saying, okay, well, we already do we're
already doing GCP and AWS. Why not just
get some other guys certified in that so
that you know when Theo actually wants
to do a company he got legitimate
trainers that he could deploy and you
know say hey I got people that can train
and these guys can be my teachers and go
from there
>> that that would be for internal uh that
would be only that would be more for
recruiting more students but yeah in of
company they don't because I've taught
CISSP I don't know How many times? And
I've never had anybody like recruit me
from BSC being treated. Just doesn't
happen. It no, but they they like it.
They're like, "Oh, that you really know
it." That's how that just it just turns
them on. It doesn't You don't get
anything for
>> um
>> Well, you you could you could treat it
like um a businessman versus a business
professor.
Who you going to listen to more? The
businessman or the business professor?
Because the business professor
>> the businessman is let's call command
real money and right
>> versus the professor theory.
>> Yeah.
>> Yeah. So, I I understand what you why
you said what you said, Aaron. Like,
you're right. Like, yeah, you want guys
to go get actual knowledge, but I'm
saying but I was I I posted that as a
potential like, hey, here's what here's
something else you can do to make
yourself attractive to the market, so to
say.
>> Yeah. So basically the way again the way
I look at it is it makes our group by
far more legitimate
um towards other groups particularly for
the CompTIA groups. So we can like not
only laugh because of success but
because we got we got certified trainers
so we can like authoritatively laugh at
other groups which of course turns me
on. That's what I like. So yeah I'm I'm
for this. I I'm thinking about different
ways of actually supporting people to
actually get this certification. This
would be something I'm interested in
doing,
>> but it's it's more from a strategic
point of view within the the manosphere
to be honest.
>> Um
>> it's just this historically they said a
group of black men came together, they
they became cloud instructors and they
taught each other how to get cloud jobs
and leave. Like that's like a roof,
you know? It can't
Who who would have thought that would
happen?
>> They did it all with their own money. No
corporate sponsors, nothing. And with
YouTube was [ __ ] on them the entire
time.
>> You know, this this is just this just
part of our montage, so it's okay.
>> Yeah, I'll definitely take it. I'll
definitely take it.
>> Thank you, Larry. Yes, that's Larry. And
Larry, on Saturday, you're sharing your
screen. Are you gonna share something
else? or Chewbacca is going to share
something with you.
>> I'll be ready.
>> I might Can you chill?
>> Did you have pancakes? Did you have
enough carbs today?
>> Can you chill? Do you need a banana? You
had one banana. Do you need apple? No.
>> Well, well, Theo, did you have enough
Brazilas today? I think that's an
important one.
>> I I talked with my trainer. She was in
Brazil. We we talked about some of the
problems with immigrating to Brazil to
be honest
and one of one of them is the prevalence
of kidnapping
and we just had like like a heart-to-he
heart conversation about the likelihood
of being kidnapped in Brazil.
>> Going to be 70 before he decides
>> Oh, I'm I'm going to Netherlands this
this October. The the question is is
where do when do I decide the country
and move the dogs in the gym? That's the
big
>> that's what I that's you're going to be
70.
>> No, I'm gonna leave. It's gonna happen.
I just got to figure it out. Um
>> you still don't know.
>> Michael, show your screen. Michael, show
your screen.
>> It he has not narrowed it down the
entire time I've been in class. I'm
guessing it's for Rob.
>> I get closer I get closer to narrowing
it down and then I look at more
information and it's like are you
willing to accept this negative point?
>> Have you heard
of the phrase
analysis paralysis?
>> Well, I don't want to be kidnapped.
>> Go to Japan then.
>> Yeah.
>> I want to go Japan.
>> Done. Japan done a lot.
>> You can you can buy a resi
just get a bulletproof car, ship it to
Brazil.
>> I don't want I don't want it. Well, I I
ride a bike.
I don't want to have to I don't want to
have to worry about being shot at 2
o'clock in the morning while I'm running
my
>> Fair enough.
>> Just who I am.
>> I think it sounds like you you have some
street smarts though. I mean, like we
got guys in Brazil and they don't get
>> they got bullets like
it happens in all areas. That's the
problem. I
>> You're in Texas. They got more bullets
in Texas than the entire country.
>> But I know how to deal with this in
Texas.
>> It's not an issue.
>> Have you considered uh getting like
private security?
>> I if I need to get private, that's a no.
That's That's red. That's no.
So that was originally why I said no to
Rio
>> because the house I wanted was going to
require private security.
>> Get kidnapped.
>> All right. All right. All right. We need
to focus. We got to help out the Mr.
Dale. So,
>> hey fellas, I had to change rooms and
change my Wi-Fi. So, I didn't see the um
when you went to um task five when you
got the API endpoints.
So is prod is prod deployed?
>> It said so. Successful created
deployment for API gateway. Okay.
>> Then go up here for the details on on
this
API gateway.
>> So see you you deployed it twice which
is why you have two there but that's
fine. So,
>> and that's
>> scrolling down makes it hard to
annotate, but
>> it's okay. So, this is the one that
would match the lab because you see we
have
>> the URL.
And then, hold on, let me change colors
here. What's a good next color? This
one. And we have the deployment.
And then we're going to have to add
slash
endpoint
which is going to be the actual function
and then
slash
query
which is going to give the API the info
it needs. Wow, that Q was really like
pick me. There we go.
Okay, thank you. So, how do I where do I
add them or do I just put them in the uh
browser and then and type them in?
>> Just copy and paste that that URL you
got.
>> Mhm.
>> And then what did you name uh your
endpoints?
or your routes.
>> Okay, give me one second.
>> So, you see where it says routes?
>> I'm looking for one moment.
It's in the left under develop.
>> Under develop. Yes, I see it now.
>> Okay. Okay. So you have one called node
and one called python. So choose one of
those.
>> Uhhuh.
>> And then now you need your query string.
So that always starts with a question
mark.
>> Okay.
>> And then the name of our query string is
name. Just like for when we did the
test.
>> Look at my screen.
>> Look at my screen right now. I got it
right. I got it right there.
>> Okay. Name. All right. Yes. Got it.
>> So, it's in the remember it's in the
documentation. Got it right there. So,
let's go and use it there.
>> All right.
>> And just hit enter.
>> No, no, look at look at the screen. Look
at my screen.
>> Oh, give me a second. Give me a second.
I'm sharing my screen. That's why I
wasn't looking at your screen. All
right. Now, me let me see. Okay. Name
equals.
And the node one was Malgus.
>> No, you could.
>> It doesn't matter.
>> Doesn't matter.
Name it Aaron.
>> Yeah.
>> Name it whatever you like. It's going to
be what it give the information that it
gives the API.
>> Good.
>> Okay.
>> Oh, he put a question mark
uh next to the query. Oh, that's wrong.
Yeah.
>> Hold on. All right. So, I need to remove
the the slash.
>> No, no,
>> go ahead.
>> Yeah. Yeah. No, wait. Yeah, that the
forward slash remove.
>> Yep. Enter.
There you go.
>> Thank you very much. I really appreciate
it, fellas.
>> Now, change node. The word node. Change
it to Python.
>> Yes, sir.
>> There you go.
>> Thank you very much, fellas. Thank you.
>> Yeah, Mike.
>> Were you paying attention, Larry? You're
doing this first thing I'll do.
>> I'll get it.
>> Yeah, it's Larry. We're going to open
the Zoom session and and we're
immediately going to start yelling at
you to share your screen.
>> Oh, well,
>> I'm be ready. It's just I just need
Tuesday's clarifications like I was
telling my buddy.
>> We We can
>> I'll be ready. I
>> You know what we can do? We We can have
Larry just provide his notes and then he
then he just walks everyone through.
>> Yeah, Larry is going to teach Saturday.
We did Charles's uh you know I said I
was taking notes and I did exactly like
I
>> I remember that one time you said you
you said you were taking
>> I got the outputs just like Charles
wanted and Rob wanted and I'll be ready.
I'll be ready.
>> I am embarrassed though. I you know I am
embarrassed but I'll be ready.
>> You're just preparing yourself. That's
all.
>> That's all. That's all.
>> You'll be You'll be ready, Larry.
>> I will.
>> Yes.
>> But I'm going to go to Waffle House on
Saturday just to have a pre-sale.
>> Me and Lis will be with you
>> to get ready for you.
>> Hold on. What What is this tag teaming?
Wherever you got that from, Rob, you're
that person's friend.
You Oh. Oh.
Oh, damn. My bad. I didn't know.
>> Bangers. Y'all be having some bangers,
boy.
>> No. No, I don't.
>> I still got that same one all the way
from 2024. I have
>> I don't know what you're talking about.
>> I'm finding I'm finding a a way where I
can utilize that in the class so I can
show everybody how you inspired me that
day.
>> I still have it.
>> Yeah, I'll get it.
what you are talking about, my friend.
>> Yes, you do. Yes, you do.
>> Yes, you do.
>> Oh, anyway.
>> Okay, I listen. I'm just waiting on you
to get your notes, man. Your notes
inspire all of us.
>> I'll be ready for that.
>> So, remember guys, your homework is to
do the W section. It's It's written
right there. Lab A WF MD. It's right
It's all here. All the instructions are
here. You guys can do this. It won't be
hard. All right. Um, I think my
formatting is is there. It's it's easy
enough to do. If you guys want to do the
be a man, please do lesson C because the
Terraform is sitting right there.
You can just do go straight to it. Oh,
there you go, Larry. Okay, we like that.
All right. But she only goes for cloud
engineers, just so you know.
>> Oh, hold on. Oh, I I got I got one good
one. I got one. I got This is the last
one, I swear. Last one. Y'all y'all will
like this one. It'll be a
a win all around. Okay.
>> Got to admit this first one you sent
over, this really reminds me of I know
she's not Venezuelan, but she just
reminds me of the Afro Venezuelan.
>> You I don't like you.
>> I'm serious. That's Does she have that
cut on the build? You know, she taller.
>> This guy likes to twist the effing
knife. What is it? Would you
>> I should I I maybe I should tolerate
kidnapping. Go to go to Japan.
>> Oh my goodness.
>> Yeah, she was a little bit like that.
No, she was a little just a No, she
didn't have curly hair. She had light
she had straight hair. But yeah,
>> I I like these honeys. These are good.
Just saying
>> this guy,
>> I I approve.
>> He's that that's all in the Brazil
folder. So,
>> all right.
>> The issue with Brazil is that if I live
there, I'm going have to live in a
bubble.
>> Yeah.
>> And my Brazilian trainer
>> also is going to have to live in a
bubble if she returns. And we had a good
conversation about that. Like, what is
it? Are we willing to accept we're
living in a bubble in the country?
>> Well, you're going to live in a bubble
where wherever you leave the states
because you're going to be in that upper
crust.
>> Dude, if I'm in Japan, I'm just a normal
person.
>> That's a That's a high That's a That's a
high trust high trust first world
country,
>> right?
>> Robo Robo. Robo. He He lives in a bubble
now and he's in the States.
>> That's true. Yeah. You should just do
You should do You should do what? What
with uh you should do what Lonnie said.
Just buy just create your own town in in
the US.
>> I'm not do I'm still in the US. No, no,
no, no. I'm out of here. I am in uh
Lonnie. Yes. Sorry, Omar. Correct. So,
homework is here.
I'll put it here.
>> Let's see here.
Fact,
>> I can I can change the name. Hold on.
I'll just change the name real quick.
work
there. Now you got it.
>> Okay. Yeah. So I'm just Yeah, I I see
what you guys just live with a certain
level of possibility of being kidnapped.
Um I really don't want to be I don't
want to have fear of kidnapping.
it, you know, the US has a level two
travel advisory against Brazil.
Of course, people have travel advisors
against the United States, but I'm not
going to stay here. I'm leaving for a
reason. See you, Carlton.
So, I I just that's just one of my
trepidations.
Yep. See, that's So,
I Let's just say this. I always tend to
go back to Brazil. It's kind of like I
think of another country and then
Brazil. Another country in Brazil. It
just kind of flows back to Brazil. Can I
accept this level? Can I accept the
possibility of being kidnapped? That's
what's going to come down.
>> Heavy.
>> It's heavy, man.
What my therapist says is, "Do you want
to know what a therapist will listen?"
He says, "It's going to come down to the
piece of ass you find." Then that's the
control. That's going to do it.
>> Until that happens, not you're not going
to know that.
>> And just that that's it.
>> No, I don't want to. See, I don't want
to see like it's just like live in
Colombia and then go to your condo and I
I don't want that. No.
No, I I kind of
>> Why are you limit one place?
>> Like you're not going to travel
afterwards. You've been traveling all
your life.
>> But I I tend to go to one place and
stay.
That's what it is. So like I go to
Tokyo, house in Tokyo, right? I'm in
Austin, house in Austin.
So if I go to another place, I'm going
to have a house and I have all my [ __ ]
transported over there and I'm going to
have a gym transported over there and
then I'm going to make a plotting
studio. So I have something going on.
I'm going to stay there and then do
immigration to them.
I'm not I'm not a hermit. I'm not a
tiger. I'm a lion.
Like what do you got? What do you got?
My therapist knows me. We've we've we've
talked. He's well aware of my me
changing the countries, but he's aware
of why.
>> Yeah.
The way he thinks of it, it's like this
is kind of funny. He's like, "If you
could live in a safe place in Colombia
and have a decent Thai woman, it' be it
would be conversation over. We wouldn't
even be talking anymore."
>> Exactly.
>> Colombia has the best land.
It's it it has reasonable taxation, but
it just has the best land. And then for
long term for this program, it's is
actually the best area. So, I'm kind of
5050 regarding Colombians, but a decent
Thai woman, I'd bang her around a sec.
And my my therapist understands that.
They know this strongest attraction. So,
it's like, okay, how do we deal with
this? For safety, I think Southeast Asia
will be a nice bet. But for our love, I
think, you know, Central South America,
especially South America.
When I was in Braz when I was in Japan
16 years, I didn't think about South
America. I was I was thinking about one
thing that was Japanese women. I did not
care about any other women at all.
>> Good job, Joan. I like it.
No, I I didn't I didn't care.
I had I had ideal women right in front
of me. Why Why would I need another
country women? I was
>> Have you always narrowed it down to the
countries you want? Like the woman of
the countries you want?
>> It's it's always moving between four
countries.
>> Okay.
>> Mainly. So it it moves be between
Chung Mai, Thailand, which is a minor
one. Prague.
Um, what is it? I forgot the name of the
Netherlands. There's a university town
in the Netherlands. And then, uh, Port,
it's actually south of Brazil. So, Porto
algor.
That's it. So, those that's usually how
it's moving. It's usually moving in that
kind of. And so
the fluctuations can be pretty big. So
if I go to Prague, it's mainly so that I
can hit on Russian and Ukrainian for
it's the best area for me to do that.
I'm not going to DR. There's no way.
Nope. No DR. No, no, no, no, no.
I I work with guys from the I work with
I got team members from the DR, man.
Great great people, great great humans,
but it's like it's like it's from it's
like they're from the the from the from
the Spanish hood, man. Like,
>> they're doing the same [ __ ]
>> Too many fat goods and sailing,
bro. So, when it comes to South America,
I I'll just throw it to these guys real
quick. It's basically this area through
here that I'm looking at specifically.
That's it. It just gives like for
quality of life, expats, internet
connection,
um sushi, big thing, ability to buy
sushi, ability to get Japanese rice, uh
Korean ramen, things like that. This
area gives me quite a lot of good. So,
it's basically from Santiago all the way
to Porto Allegre. Um, I've had Feripa is
a strong second candidate, but the big
one also here is Asencio.
So, really I like this. Well, for me, I
look at this as being one geographical
area.
Geographical area number two
is
here
in I love Berlin. I can't live there
because I would have to spend a lot of
money to live there. But to be able to
go there once per quarter, I'm down. So
it's basically Prague through these
areas here, Hungary, Slovakia with a
secondary with Warso
gives me pretty much what I want. Um,
the other thing it has in common with
the southern part of South America is
that it has winter.
I'm focusing on winter,
right?
So these are the these are the like the
super areas that I'm really thinking
about.
Not Germany. So like I go to Germany for
a vacation from time to time. Paris, I
love going to Paris. Milano is right
there. These are also areas where I want
to go to is very close, very easy to
communicate to.
This is where it's going down.
If my the way my again my therapist has
it. If I can go to Prague in two days,
meet a decent Thai woman, game over.
Done. I moved to Prague. I'm married
Tai, made kids.
>> At this point, it just sounds like if
you find a Thai chick anywhere in the
world that's not Thailand, you pretty
much said
>> it would. So, like if I met a Thai woman
in the United States, I would move her
out of the United States.
>> No. Okay. Okay. All right. All right.
Fair.
>> All right. Theo. Yes. Outside the
states, if you met her in Netherlands,
if you met her in Hoto, if you met her
in, you know, Medí, if you met her in Sa
Paulo, and you met a Thai woman, then
you like, "All right, I'm walking it
down."
>> Yeah. But it's like the other one is if
I met a Brazilian in Prague,
I go for it.
Same thing if I met Afro Venezuelan in
Prague.
>> You you you just just you don't want
that. Just just leave it alone. Okay.
>> But it's the legal it's the lot of
things with taxation law long-term
ability to buy property things like
this. This is these are major issues for
long term. So I have to go through and
study that. This is why there's
fluctuations. So like why do I avoid
Germany laws taxation
France taxation 100% Spain taxation UK
taxation it's no way uh Netherlands
taxation very tax friendly very very
nice place has has a lot of benefits
they need people want corporate taxes
low dealing with government and paying
taxes it's actually very amenable this
is this is why I like Mud loads. Poland
even better. Just [ __ ] really [ __ ]
cold. Um, Polish women are just a little
too white for me. I don't know.
Just
kind of don't don't do it exactly for
me.
Kimman type.
>> When I like when I when I usually like
um like Ukrainian women, they usually
have some sort of blend of either
Turkish or Crimea inside of them. So
they're a little darker. Not entirely,
but they're still darker.
That's something I don't want them have.
They need SPF 100 at midnight like my
mom.
It's like I don't like it that I don't
like this. So, um if you know I would
love Venezuela or Colombia, they have
some good points. Uh
not entirely, but they have some good
points. Again, Colombia, Kali, Medigene
have some very good points. So to be
honest, these two cities are the base
standard. This is where I actually st
establish where is actually possible for
me to go longterm out of the country.
And they have extremely good points.
Just doesn't have everything that I
want.
>> Hey yo, they got everything you want in
Panama. They got everything in Panama.
>> No, man. Forget Panama now.
>> Let's go to Panama next week. pick get
the Panama band going next week.
>> There's too many too many around new.
>> Yeah, that's what that's what le going
for. He's like, "Hey, I'm trying to go
to the old block satellite in Panama
City."
>> It'll be a key right at my favorite taco
style.
>> Oh, no. That's what that's that's what
that's what she's there for. Like, oh, I
know you came here for them tacos, but
you should go for them for these cheese
grits, Larry. Come on. Got cheese grits.
>> Cheese grits. I had to bring Omar with
me, man, for that man. New
>> Yeah. Yeah. I see I see you over there
in Panama. Yeah. Yeah.
>> Hell no. No. No. No. I'm deal with that.
>> Cheese grits.
>> Yeah. That's what that you you went to
Panama to get authentic cheese grits,
Larry. You ain't there to go get some
tacos? You don't want some?
>> I said I said kiss my cheese grits.
Hell no.
Oh, my bad. That's why that's why you
going out to Thailand. Yeah, you gota go
pay. Got to go Bangkok and pay. That's
that's where it be at. They sell when
cheese grits out that you know what that
that's what that's what they have out in
Thailand, man. They got cheese grits in
Thailand. No. That's what you want,
right?
>> I just hope the brothers are holding
stands that not even looking their way.
>> They they You don't even need on the
real. You don't even need to worry about
them. You got top tier
chicks making themsel Okay, you know
what? Here, here, here. That's what what
here's an example. Okay, so
I put in a IG link and we we really do
need to get a sports team. We need to
sponsor a sports team, but that's that's
in the near future. Anyways, so that
link I just put up right there,
>> that's Mexico. You could find like
that's like a mid to that's like a six
or that's like a six or seven or eight
in Mexico.
>> This has become a more of a narco state
now from my from my taste. Man, they to
take over Colombians.
>> Why did Why is that
>> state?
>> I'm not worried about I'm not worried
about them being a narco state. Same the
same. It's the same thing with Colombia.
Narco state.
>> Former NCO state.
>> Wow. They're Wow. Beautiful.
>> Oh yeah. Air train ones. Oh yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Air trains. Oh yeah. Top
tier. Top tier. If you like chocolate,
air tray is always on the table. Always.
>> Wow. Wow.
>> Best best chocolate in the world. I I I
say that with no hesitation. Best
chocolate in the world. If you look for
pure chocolate, that's what that's what
they're looking for.
>> I don't understand why I say I don't
know why I say it's is 18 plus, but
whatever.
>> I don't care.
>> So, yeah, this chocolate one. Wow. Oh
boy.
Yeah, this Yeah, I got
>> get
deal over to Africa. Get the Africa.
>> Yeah, no problem with that. Yeah, that
see that that goes right in line with
this for me as far as I'm concerned.
>> Oh my god.
>> No, no problems there. It's not been an
issue. But and why I do that is I'm very
serious about state issues like can
foreigners own property
uh deportation rules, taxation, I have
to go through this entire process. So
for example, Brazil is really good if
you stay there less than 180 days.
It's like a dream come true.
Anything after 180 days per year, we
have you have a problem. So my trainer
and her husband stay in Brazil 179 days
per year.
If they stay anything more, her husband
has to pay taxes.
Yeah.
>> Can you do like uh the Philippines just
after the one
179th day go and leave and come back
>> uh two three days later and start all
over again or No,
>> I don't think you understand Filipino.
>> Oh, you said 180 days a year. Okay.
>> I don't think you understand Filipinos.
Okay. No, I'm talking about uh you said
um
>> if you're with if you're with Filipinos
in the Philippines,
>> they make sure you can't pull out.
>> So, you're stuck there.
>> Okay, I'm well aware of that. The
Philippines. So, you you have to be
gung-ho. You have to be like, I'm going
to Philippines. I'm going to marry a
Filipina and I'm going to pump her
brain. That's the only thing you think
of the Philipp you have to you have to
have like an invasion mentality with
that country or else it's just it
doesn't make sense why you're there.
They're going to think like you're gay
or something because they're like why
aren't you banging one? They all want to
bang here.
>> That's that's the way that's the way it
is abroad, man.
>> They don't have to worse. They don't
have anything. That's that's just
so Yeah.
>> All right. My my my last link. My last
one for the night. My bad. I'm going
crazy.
>> That's That's for Larry. Well,
>> I appreciate
>> There you go, Larry. I appreciate that,
bro. A man after my own heart. That's no
good, man. Yeah.
>> So, that's what you want, Larry. Okay. I
I get you.
>> This this this kind of stuff right here
would This would be tempting right now.
>> Wait.
Like like Eron, like Erin said, he's all
over here.
At least his classics that I know.
>> Oh my gosh.
Oh my she
ain't You didn't get me. Did you Did you
get
>> No, that ain't it.
Yeah.
>> Oh goodness. Oh, that that's a good
laugh.
>> That's a that's a good laugh. So, a gym
a a thick gym a thick Colombian gym
girly Marina
>> at your gym. At your gym, Theo, come on.
I got the gym equipment. I I don't like
necessarily like Yeah, it's kind of
okay. Gym equipment.
>> Listen, if Okay, let's be frank.
Something like someone like her going to
Theo's gym, that's She's a regular.
That's that that's a that's the standard
that the streets
>> that that's the standard like like the
the type of chicks that deal get to his
gym. That's the standard. Like he he
going he's going to get way better
looking chicks than her. Let's be let's
be frank.
>> Yeah, that that's true. Yeah, my gym's
going to be expensive.
>> Exactly. So, like she's going to go a
smart fit, but like the the the swim
version of her could probably afford to
get the deal.
>> No, this is the version that I want at
my gym.
>> Oh, that's what that's what you want.
>> Yeah, that's what I want. That's this is
what the the gym is designed to thirst
trap these women particularly because
I'm bringing women'sbased gym equipment
there. It's actually one section
>> and the the kind of gym equipment that
aren't see Kevin that isn't really used
that much in that country.
>> Yep.
>> Oh goodness.
>> As my my therapist says, he's like
he's like, "Yeah, you've got a bad hip.
You're using certain kind of gym
equipment in order to do rehab." Just
just true. By the way, that general
equipment is also really liked by women
and it isn't international that often,
right? Because came new. So, it's
somewhat it's a little bit in Texas or
America, but it's international. It's
not used that much. So, he's like, "Oh,
okay. So, your hip rehab is going to get
you a chick. It's going to get you the
It's like your thirst trap." He's like
He's like, "That's smart. That's
actually like a really good tactic."
Like like Yeah. He's like, "I understand
what you're doing there." Yeah, I'm not
stupid.
So anyway, I like that. I should go talk
to Chachi BT about that. Start running
numbers.
>> It's It's East Africa. So, Ethiopia. Uh
>> yeah. Yeah. I I I have to I have to run
all the numbers. There's a whole slew of
analysis I do to a different area.
>> You'd be better off just importing just
finding air train East African chicks in
Morocco and then just working from
there.
>> Black Muslim wants me in Morocco so bad.
>> Well, because it's I mean like it I
can't think of any other spot outside of
Morocco and South Africa. Can't really
think of a spot that you can relative
you can relatively go to that has what
you're looking for.
>> Why take it?
>> Because I cuz I could say, "Oh, you
should just wait for me to go and go to
Nigeria and terraform it." Yeah. It's
going to take like 40 years.
>> You don't want to do that.
>> I see. I see.
>> So, you know, and then Egypt Egypt is
tripping right now. So um
>> Oh no,
no, Morocco was again Chachi BT came
straight out and said I should go there.
That was back in November.
>> Yep.
>> So well guys, good class. I had fun
talking to you guys. Uh I will see you
guys all on Saturday. Okay. Going to
have some more additions to the lab.
Larry
>> Larry's gonna be teaching
>> and good job. I thought you guys did a
great job. So uh I'll see you later.
Okay.
Stoping beding.